for many years I've personally been
dreaming of the iPhone being good enough
in terms of the camera to replace a real
professional camera so the question is
has that day finally come and I think
yes it has so in this video I'm gonna
explain what has changed over the years
especially with the latest iPhone 14 Pro
Models to make it so good and especially
showing off my own use case where it
finally is good enough but first we
gotta go through a little bit of Story
Time way back in 2016 the co-host Max
and I were working for Apple Insider
growing their YouTube channel and that
is a year when Apple released the iPhone
7 plus and that's when it came with dual
cameras and the brand new portrait mode
feature now at first it didn't work that
well but the background blur was there
and that's when I saw started thinking
hey imagine if this gets good enough to
eventually look like a pro camera and
then year after year they kept improving
the portrait mode making it better then
eventually adding foreground blur to
make it more realistic like a real
camera would do then improving the depth
with the lidar scanner on the back of
the Pro Models and then finally a couple
years back they added cinematic video
mode which was a dream come true but it
was limited to 1080p resolution so I
personally didn't really use it that
often but now with the iPhone 14 Pro
Models it is finally perfected and I'm
telling you it is absolutely amazing so
let me explain everything that goes into
it now if it wasn't already clear to you
I'm using my iPhone 14 pro to record
this in cinematic video and I've got to
tell you it actually looks really really
good now one of the biggest drawbacks to
replace using a pro camera with an
iPhone is the audio situation because
usually we use a professional microphone
that's out of the frame right now but
for the iPhone you don't really have
many solutions especially at a distance
like this with the raw iPhone audio
sounding pretty bad but thankfully we
have modern solutions like the m650
microphone from our partner anchor work
that I've actually been using to record
the audio for this entire video it
features an all-in-one design like the
airpods so you could use it anywhere
packing two wireless microphones that
you can either clip onto your shirt or
magnetically attach through your shirt
like I am right now with six different
color options and a wireless receiver
that's easy to connect to any phone
since it has both lightning and USBC
adapters giving you excellent microphone
quality for instant recording or live
streaming on the go with true Link
Wireless technology which uses lc3 Plus
for long range 656 foot connection each
one of these is going to last six hours
or even up to 15 with the wireless
charging case and the receiver comes
with a touch screen LCD display to view
your audio levels and make changes to
your settings it also has dual Channel
Wireless recording and voice Shield Pro
noise reduction just hear the difference
for yourself this is the audio quality
of the iPhone by itself and this is the
audio quality of the Anker m650
microphone that's definitely a massive
Improvement and you can check it out
using the link below now getting back to
how my iPhone 14 pro has replaced a pro
camera for me the main new difference is
that the iPhone 14 pro supports 4K
cinematic video recording mode and that
takes the quality to a whole different
level just check out this footage of
wake surfing in the summer with
background tumbler in the back looking
absolutely amazing I mean this is Pro
Camera level of video quality but the
main reason for why it's replaced a pro
camera for me is because I can finally
take my iPhone 14 pro home and shoot
professional quality b-roll of products
to review with the iPhone instead of a
pro camera and it looks absolutely
amazing we've been doing some sponsored
reviews and usually I'd have to take my
camera but with the iPhone with 4K
cinematic mode it looks just as good
with the convenience of being in my
pocket at all times but what makes it
really special to me and why I love how
Apple implemented it is that you can
change the amount of background blur in
post so right now you guys can see it's
changing between a lot of blur and a
small amount of blur because we're doing
it in post while editing you can even
change the focus in post which is an
insane ain't changed that they've added
so right now you can probably see it's
out of focus now it's back in Focus
because you can change it in post
switching between people in the
foreground and background and I've
actually implemented this myself as you
can see here's some footage of my kids
at home and right here at this moment I
swish the focus on my older son sitting
at the kitchen island and then back to
my younger son while I was recording
this wasn't even in post now imagine you
could do it in post anytime you want
that is absolutely amazing and is so
important because a lot of times with
the professional camera once it records
something and if the focus gets wrong
and off you're kind of screwed you have
to reshoot the whole video if you want
everything to be nice and focus but with
the iPhone you can change it in post and
that is absolutely Priceless so
basically I have never been this happy
with video footage coming coming out of
an iPhone especially with the Cinematic
video mode now in 4k looking absolutely
amazing with Incredible quality now I
have to get into the actual portrait
photo mode and this is absolutely
awesome because they've been working on
it for the last few years and they have
perfected it the foreground blur looks
amazing the actual colors look awesome
just look at these portrait mode photos
of sunsets and subjects during a sunset
it really brings out those sunset colors
while other phones like the s23 ultra
they kind of cut it down and they can't
reproduce it so the iPhone is killing it
in terms of portrait photography so much
so that I'd say that it's rivaling
professional digital cameras now one of
the biggest advantages the iPhone has
compared to a real professional digital
camera is that it has a ton of
processing power and therefore we have
portrait night mode code photos which
look absolutely insane it's able to
bring it up while using portrait mode
and it looks just so much better than
what digital cameras can make out at
night because of course they suffer in
terms of low light quality and that's
where they win compared to digital
cameras now another big change is the 48
megapixel main camera and unfortunately
Apple forces you to use Pro raw not just
the regular heic or jpeg formats but
what this means is that when you switch
to prora and you take a photo you get
insane levels of detail that you can't
get without using it and I found this
really useful for group photos where you
have a lot of people and you want it to
look as good as possible so that you
could share it online or do whatever
with it the difference in quality is
awesome and of course it sucks that they
force you to use Pro raw but we have
found a shortcut on the iPhone through
the show shortcuts app where you can
literally book reformat Pro Raw photos
into heic right on your phone at any
time and it only takes seconds and you
can even make it delete the pro raw
photo to use less space so if you're
interested in how to do that I'll leave
a link in the video description below to
my tweet thread now the only thing I'm
disappointed about in terms of the
iPhone's camera is the 3x lens because
there is a big difference in quality
this year between that specific
telephoto lens and the rest of the
camera the Selfies got a lot better A
lot more sharp the main camera is huge
in terms of the difference and the ultra
wide even got a big upgrade but the 3x
lens it falls down because you can see a
lot of the noise especially when the
light kind of comes down and it's a more
dimly lit situation that's why I rarely
use the 3x because there's just such a a
big difference and thankfully with the
iPhone 15 Pro Models apple is working on
fixing that hopefully they give us a 3X
to 6X telephoto zoom lens hopefully that
gives us a lot better Zoom quality so
with all that said I've got to say that
this is the first year and first time an
iPhone has ever replaced a digital
camera for me in the real world
especially being able to use it for
product reviews that I do at home it is
just on a whole another level and the
Cinematic 4K mode destroys the
competition in terms of the Android
phones s23 Ultra everything it just
kills it especially because of the
stabilization to match it it just got so
much better this year so it's perfectly
stabilized and just I've never been this
excited as you can tell about iPhone
photography and videography I've Gotta
Give A Bravo to Apple for the
refinements and I looked forward to what
they have in store for the future let me
know what you guys think in the comment
section below click that Circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign